January 1986 was a pivotal time for the
National Aeronautics and Space
Administration
in response to the Reagan
administration's directive that the
reusable space shuttle would serve as
America's sole launch vehicle for the
foreseeable future
NASA had ramped up its launch schedule
from just five missions in 1984 to nine
in 1985.
by 1988 NASA's four shuttles Columbia
Challenger Discovery and Atlantis were
expected to be flying 24 missions per
year two per month through the end of
the 20th century
but as 1986 dawned there were signs that
this ambitious schedule might be too
ambitious
the Columbia Mission designated as
sts-61c originally scheduled for
December 18 1985 had been postponed
seven times before it finally launched
from Kennedy Space Center on January
12th
this Mission had attracted considerable
media attention because its crew
included U.S congressman Bill Nelson
but now the persistent delays we're
provoking intense media criticism and
with good reason if this one Mission
experienced nearly four weeks of delays
how could NASA possibly achieve a
sustained rate of two launches per month
the next mission
sts-51l Challenger was scheduled to
launch on January 24th and this flight
was attracting even more attention
because it would inaugurate NASA's much
publicized teacher in Space Project
crew member Christa McAuliffe a social
studies teacher from Concord New
Hampshire would be teaching several
lessons from space and millions of
school children were expected to tune in
but the embarrassing launch
postponements continued on January 24th
due to high winds at an emergency
landing site in Africa on the 25th due
to poor weather at Kennedy and on the
27th due to a mundane mechanical problem
a stuck door handle
just as this problem was fixed a cold
front swept across Eastern Florida and
the accompanying high winds prompted yet
another postponement
that night the local temperature
plummeted to 18 degrees Fahrenheit and
because the launch pad used large
quantities of sprayed water for sound
suppression there were serious concerns
about ice buildup on the pad and on the
shuttle throughout the night ground
Crews worked diligently to remove as
much ice as possible and on the morning
of the 28th NASA imposed a two-hour
delay to allow the Rising Sun to finish
the job
the countdown resumed end at 11 38 a.m
sts-51l Challenger lifted off
rolled onto its planned trajectory
and soared majestically into a clear
blue sky
about 40 seconds into the flight right
on schedule
Challenger's main engines were throttled
back to 65 percent as the vehicle passed
through the altitude at which Maximum
aerodynamic loading would occur
as the engines were subsequently
throttled back up to full power Mission
Control informed the crew Challenger go
at throttle up
Mission Commander dick scoby's response
Roger go at throttle up was the final
transmission received from sts-51l
one second later the vehicle was
engulfed in a cloud of white smoke
a shower of flaming debris arced toward
the Atlantic and the shuttle's two
booster Rockets spiraled crazily across
the sky
after a long pause NASA's live TV
broadcast provided a tourist report
obviously a major malfunction we have a
report from the flight Dynamics officer
that the vehicle has exploded
the Challenger disaster was one of those
traumatic events that will be forever
seared into the consciousness of all who
experienced it if you were alive in 1986
you probably remember exactly where you
were when you heard those haunting words
the vehicle has exploded
this tragedy which killed Seven
astronauts and threw the U.S Space
Program into crisis was all the more
tragic because the underlying
engineering design flaw had been
identified long before the first space
shuttle ever flew and was well
understood at the time of Challengers
launch
why wasn't this flaw addressed
well we'll answer this question in
today's lesson
and in doing so we'll learn that the
Challenger disaster was as much a
failure of organizational decision
making as it was in engineering failure
let's begin our analysis by examining
the technological system at the heart of
this case
formally named the space transportation
system or STS the space shuttle was
developed as the successor to NASA's
Apollo program which had successfully
landed 12 men on the moon between 1969
and 1972.
the shuttle program's principal goal was
to reduce the cost of space flight
through the development of a reusable
launch vehicle consisting of four major
components
the Orbiter
powered by three liquid-fueled main
engines
the external tank which held 1.6 million
pounds of liquid hydrogen and liquid
oxygen to power the orbiter's engines
and two solid rocket boosters or srbs
which supplied additional thrust
on a typical Mission the orbiter's main
engines and both srbs were used to
propel the vehicle off the launch pad
after the srbs had expended most of
their propellant they were jettisoned
returned to Earth by Parachute and
recovered for reuse
then about eight minutes into the flight
the orbiter's main engines were shut
down
and the external tank was jettisoned
the orbiter's two small maneuvering
engines were then fired to insert the
vehicle into orbit
finally upon completion of its Mission
the Orbiter re-entered the Earth's
atmosphere
and glided to a landing at either
Kennedy Space Center Florida or Edwards
Air Force Base California
although the shuttle design was based on
detailed NASA specifications the system
was designed and built entirely by
contractors the Orbiter by Rockwell
International the main engines by
Rocketdyne the external tank by Martin
Marietta the solid rocket Motors by
Morton thiacal and the remaining SRB
components by United space boosters
as we'll see the Challenger explosion
originated in one of the solid rocket
boosters so let's look more closely at
this important component of the system
each SRB was 109 feet long 12 feet in
diameter and composed of the nose cap
and frustum which includes the booster's
parachutes
the forward skirt which contained
Avionics
the AFT skirt which was bolted to the
launch pad to hold the shuttle in
position as its engines were powered up
prior to liftoff
the solid rocket motor consisting of
four cylindrical steel cases filled with
solid propellant
and a bell-shaped nozzle which was
integral with a motor's aft segment
these motor segments were fabricated at
Morton thiacal's Factory in Utah then
shipped by rail to the vertical Assembly
Building at Kennedy Space Center where
they were stacked and connected together
at three field joints
these field joints had two critical
functions
to connect the steel case segments
together structurally and to prevent hot
high pressure propellant gases from
leaking out of the motor during its two
minute burn
failure of either function would likely
cause a catastrophic loss of the entire
shuttle
the field joint configuration was a tang
and clevis connection
as we can see in this cutaway the bottom
edge of the upper case the Tang was
inserted into the u-shaped upper edge of
the lower case the clevis then locked in
position with 177 steel pins
this small gap between the tang and
clevis was sealed with two O-rings made
of heat resistant synthetic Rubber and
mounted within two grooves in the inner
half of the Clevis
the purpose of these O-rings was to
prevent hot high pressure propellant gas
from leaking out of the motor
we'll see how they performed this
function shortly
each steel case segment was insulated
from the propellant by a thick rubber
coating
at the field joint the Gap in this
insulation layer was filled with heat
resistant zinc chromate putty which
provided a thermal barrier to protect
the O-rings from the hot propellant
gases that would fill this open space
between the case segments as soon as the
rocket motor ignited
it's important to emphasize that the
soft zinc chromate Putty was not
intended to seal the joint but rather
just to protect the O-rings so that the
O-rings could seal the joint without
being damaged by hot combustion gases
so how did these O-rings seal the field
joint well enough to contain the
extremely high gas pressure generated
inside the SRB
well the O-rings and the grooves in
which they were mounted were designed to
provide a redundant pressure actuated
seal
when the rocket motor ignited the
resulting internal pressure would be
transmitted through the soft zinc
chromate putty
then it would force the primary o-ring
across its Groove
and flatten it against the grooves
Downstream face
causing the O-ring to extrude into the
gap between the tang and Clevis
thus creating a robust seal
the most ingenious aspect of this
technology is that the O-ring which was
designed to contain the high pressure
generated within the SRB was also sealed
by this same internal pressure
and if for some reason the primary
o-ring failed to seal then the secondary
o-ring would seal by the same Dynamic
process
and this joint looked great on paper but
from the time it was designed in the
early 1970s until the Challenger
disaster in 1986 it was plagued by a
succession of increasingly serious
problems
the first problem surfaced in 1977 four
years before the first shuttle flight
when Morton thiacal was conducting tests
to verify that the srb's steel case
could withstand the internal pressure
generated by propellant combustion
in these tests
internal pressure caused a slight
outward ballooning of the SRB segments
steel case
and this deformation
unexpectedly caused the gap between the
tang and clevis to open by just a few
hundredths of an inch this opening
called Joint rotation was large enough
to prevent the O-rings from sealing
reliably
although this condition seemed to pose a
grave risk both Morton thiacal and NASA
ultimately concluded that the risk could
be managed by using slightly larger
O-rings and by inserting metal shims
between the tang and clevis to reduce
joint rotation more importantly
subsequent testing demonstrated that the
primary o-ring could be expected to seal
within 0.2 seconds of ignition while
maximum joint rotation didn't occur
until 0.6 seconds after ignition and as
long as the joint sealed before it
rotated the seal would be maintained
on this basis NASA approved viacol's SRB
design in 1980.
the first shuttle mission sts-1 Columbia
launched in April 1981 and the field
joints performed well
but when Colombia flew again seven
months later the post-flight examination
of the recovered boosters revealed a new
problem
one of the primary O-rings had been
partially burned through
this phenomenon called o-ring erosion
was eventually attributed to a jet of
hot high pressure propellant gas passing
through a tiny blowhole in the zinc
chromate putty and impinging upon the
primary o-ring
the blowhole had probably formed during
the pre-launch assembly process when
some air was trapped within the putty as
the rocket motor segments were being
joined together
although this appeared to be a serious
issue Morton thiacal eventually
determined that the resulting risk was
minimal
a gas jet capable of causing o-ring
erosion could only occur during the
fraction of a second between ignition
and the establishment of a pressure seal
and during this brief period the Jets
simply didn't have enough energy to burn
completely through an O-ring
consistent with this finding three of
the next nine shuttle missions
experienced some o-ring erosion but the
field joints continue to function
normally in all cases
then in September 1984 the recovered
boosters from sts-41d Discovery revealed
an ominous new development a phenomenon
called o-ring blow-by
in one of the factory assembled nozzle
joints a small deposit of black soot was
discovered between the primary and
secondary O-rings meaning that the
primary o-ring had initially failed to
seal and hot propellant gases had blown
by it
fortunately the secondary o-ring had
sealed properly and thus had prevented a
catastrophe
but in this particular case the
successful functioning of the secondary
o-ring was small consolation
this instance of primary o-ring blow-by
had occurred in a factory assembled
nozzle joint which was significantly
more robust and less susceptible to
Joint rotation than a field joint had
the same incident occurred in a field
joint the delay in attaining of primary
o-ring seal might have allowed enough
joint rotation to prevent the secondary
o-ring from sealing at all with
catastrophic consequences
both NASA and Morton thiacol recognize
the dire implications of this new
problem
but there was a schedule to meet and
blow-by seemed like another manageable
risk so the launches continued while
fire calls Engineers studied the problem
after three trouble-free missions
sts-51c Discovery launched on January 24
1985.
the worrisome situation got much worse
in the post-flight examination of the
recovered boosters one field joint in
each SRB showed evidence of both erosion
and blow-by
this was the first instance of blow-by
in a field joint the first time that
thermal distress had occurred in two
different field joints on the same
flight and the first occurrence of
blow-by and Joint erosion at the same
location to the engineers at thiacol
this was their nightmare come true
what had caused the sts-51c field joints
to perform so much worse than on any
previous flight
well after eliminating all of the
possibilities the engineers determined
that low temperature was the culprit the
launch from Kennedy Space Center had
been preceded by the coldest three-day
period ever recorded in Florida
at ignition the O-ring temperature was
estimated to have been 53 degrees
Fahrenheit 10 degrees lower than on any
previous launch
low temperature had several adverse
effects on the field joint but the most
important was a significant reduction in
the O-rings resilience
[Music]